Speaker 1: So last week I played for you a clip of
one of Donald Trump's new defense attorneys, Joe
Tacopina on MSNBC, being interviewed properly by
Ari MELBER and lunging at papers that Ari MELBER
was holding. That's how Joe Tacopina reacted to
an actual real interview with questions that are
not just softballs. We now have a different sort
of interview. What's interesting is that this
was a completely friendly interview. Joe Tacopina
appeared last night with Fox News's propagandist,
Mark Levin. Very comfortable interview, very
friendly. There was no lunging for papers.
But Joe Tacopina is just as unhinged. Take
a look at this. This is if this is the guy
that's going to defend Trump, if Trump is
arrested, I don't know, guys. I'm not sure.
Speaker 2: Well, let's start out with just a
basic question, one that really only has one
answer. No matter what side of the political fence
you sit on. Does anyone actually believe that if
someone else were accused of paying hush money
to avoid a publicly embarrassing sex scandal,
which the president vehemently denies? Vehemently.
Speaker 1: Right. But which, by the way,
never happened. Right, Joe?
Speaker 2: But regardless of that,
anyone else in that situation with this set of
facts, would they be prosecuted? The answer,
Mark. By all accounts, is 100% no.
Speaker 1: Now, what Joe Tacopina
and this is this is the problem. When you don't
have a real interviewer, a real show like this,
when you just have a softball thing,
is there's two issues here. Number one,
it's not that they're just going after Trump for
political reasons because Michael Cohen served
prison time for participating in this very same
criminal conspiracy. So if you want to be fair,
Michael Cohen's crimes were committed in service
to Trump. You would think that points to maybe
Trump does have some liability here. And of
course, secondly, the element of this that
Joe Tacopina doesn't include is that what is at
issue is the laundering of the hush money through
Trump's campaign. And so the idea that, oh, it's
just political, nobody else would be arrested for
hush money related to an affair, which they
don't even do. Well, we're talking about a
different situation, a different set of facts
and money laundering through a campaign. Next
clip. And again, Mark Levin is just useless here.
Speaker 2: What really is troubling because if you
think about it, all decent people, whether
politically opposed to Donald Trump or in
favor of Donald Trump, should be concerned
about this weaponization of a prosecutor's
office to go get a political opponent, because.
Speaker 1: Well, if you can prove that that's
what happened, that would be one thing. But we
know Michael Cohen went to prison over this. So
it's not merely a prosecutor saying, let's
see if we can get Trump on this. Cohen was
prosecuted and went to prison for his involvement
in this very same incident. Now, that being said,
I will admit I don't think the Stormy Daniels
case is the strongest case against Trump. But
maybe this will open the floodgates for other
prosecutors to say, all right, it's time,
it's time. Here's another clip of Tacopina When.
Speaker 2: It's cold from the dead, the Stormy
Daniels case, there is no crime here. The only
potential crime here, Mark, is that Donald Trump
was an extortion victim who says, give me money
or I'm going to tell a nasty story about you.
True or not, that's even that's absolutely
irrelevant to that equation. True or not,
I'm going to tell a story to the press that
would embarrass you, your family, unless you
give me money. That's extortion, Moral one.
Speaker 1: Now, remember whether or not Trump
had an affair with Stormy Daniels, whether or
not Stormy extorted him, which, by the way,
if it was extortion, Trump should go after her for
extortion regardless. That doesn't mean Trump had
to launder the payment through his campaign,
which is what's at issue here. You could say
she extorted money out of me and I gave her the
money for an affair that never happened. Okay,
then there wouldn't be a crime except look at how
it was handled financially. And again, Levin won't
force Tacopina to contend with that. And Tacopina
certainly isn't going to. This guy, if this is the
sort of defense that you have to remember with
people like Trump, typically you've got your TV
lawyers who say one thing and then you're court
lawyers who have to manage the situation in a
different way. Sometimes there's a little overlap,
like with that Olena Haba, who got herself into
all sorts of trouble to being both Trump's TV
lawyer and real lawyer. My hope for Trump is
that Tacopina is not actually going to be managing
this for him if indeed Trump is arrested tomorrow